[Music]
welcome to the Y roll the intro another
week another Lawai let's dig into the
memes sigh it's 4:00 a.m. time to edit
our videos sigh sigh if you miss a
deadline side then you're actually dead
how about we kick this video off with
some epic sighs appreciation leave a
nice comment this videos don't make
themself did mr. beast still sigh sigh
mr. bear
finally I'm so surprised did it say this
sooner
it's so good looks like got a little
extra pounds on me there that's right
last of us to reached out they wanted me
to be part of it and I I reluctantly
accepted it's too perfect man except I'm
probably shorter in this yeah that makes
sense
how did we never get Felix sister to
host anything at all because she lives
in Sweden that's why yeah I live in UK
yeah hey for you that don't have a dad
me are you winning oh of course you're
winning
of course what it really means to be
winning anyway huh huh
you can totally lose and still win think
about it I may have lost two teachers
I'm still winning
the Swedish pancakes after Felix makes
them what the Swedish [ __ ] everybody
oh my god
actually I should start up this video oh
my god I want to address the controversy
and I want to make an apology I was
ignorant but I've learned and I spent
the last couple days trying to better
myself I've gone to therapy and
apparently apparently Swedish pancakes
are just European camp pancakes and I
assumed that they were Swedish pancakes
because I grew up making them what the
hell man what are you gonna do tell me
pokemon is in Swedish next if I grew up
watching it and if I ate it then it's
Swedish they speak Swedish in Pokemon
you goddamn right it's Swedish it's
really this you will never understand
everyone from different countries be
like oh yeah we make them like that
except we put ham in them ooh
except I put Nutella in them at all I
put my Ricardo's peepee in them you've
heard jamming them otherwise they're not
Swedish okay Denmark may be copiers ok
Finland maybe do the same but they're
Swedish pancakes and nobody ain't nobody
gonna tell me different and I ain't
apologizing for that now or 10 years
from now glad we got that over with did
you hear it
Nutella global pee deep I said that I'm
better than you Jam big peepee to tell
us more peepee goddamn oh and Nutella
contains palm oil which kills
orangutangs
sorry orangutan killers guess you're not
so virtuous after all mr. orangutan a
killer Felix you should loosen up your
headphones a bit man yeah yeah see you
know I saw this and as soon as I saw it
I'm like yeah they're gonna make fun of
me for that damn it do I still have it
kind of my hair is getting long this is
the curse yeah I get it I get it I put
them on through hard oh it's a camel
it's a camel got it
no no good meme all done in pain - I
respect that
fair enough you get a pee-pee reward now
you already got it thank you you engage
double pancake hey it's anything for
views what the hell yeah
dope or pancake did you put jam in them
answer now or else I can't determine
size with PP Felix what if I messed it
up
it's my only good pancake marzia I need
it oh that is so cute I feel my heart
crack a year ago on this day Jurgen the
first pass away let us pay respect to
the Fallen engine it's already been a
year huh
maybe Jurgen was better off at least he
wouldn't have to live to see the
disastrous state of the earth right now
may he be find peace in heaven or see
heaven everyone that made a cocoa melon
intro first appearance yeah it's funny
because it's true keep making the intros
please it's working I was throwing out
ten thousand magic cards and the bag
ripped Jesus magic the scattering get it
instead of gathering the cards got
scattered have fun picking those up
Jesus Christ it Loki I want to go
through them so badly I don't know what
if there's a rare card in there
look you spend 10 hours find it look I
found the card that's rare it's worth
ten dollars
I made one dollar an hour the license of
a state what is this mad magnetic
motivation they're using me as an ad
yeah this happens we'll strike it down
you'll be hearing for my Swedish lawyer
beach season disease mother today we're
making Swedish pancake yeah hear this
okay great yeah I get it I get it the
rest of Europe makes the pancakes the
same way okay sure but you don't call it
Sven spunk talk it through you know you
call it black and bacon or for a good
bourbon so it ain't Swedish and why how
come there's an authentic Swedish recipe
infidelity in Swedish Swedish person
made them they're Swedish okay
minecraft Swedish you're welcome alright
just say thanks that's all I want
alright I'll buy you're welcome IKEA
yeah you're goddamn welcome alright
alright the zipper the first-aid kit
oh I'm sorry did I save your life just
now PewDiePie I'm on the list that's
funny
Pirate Bay you're welcome now what
people I want inventions people are
useless
come on Chris Nichkhun you're welcome
Alfred Nobel the mother flippin dynamite
people go boom boom you welcome I think
that means we can take the credit for
that song boom boom boom boom I want you
in my room it's a catchy song I'll take
credit for it you're welcome
oh the revolver god damn we're something
what the hell a priest at the same time
as Samuel Colt policies you saw mr. Colt
did it no mother flipping Swedish priest
out here going bang bang bang you seen a
big shooting devil says she probably had
a silver bullet to shine
sorry side for this war sunshine oh this
suing machine honestly Oh mother
flipping cream separator Oh what did you
do before they cream separator you a
douche and you would just say thank you
god damn it we walk so you could run we
made the cream separator oh I'm sorry
you thought Nikolai Tesla was the one
that pioneered all turning current it
was Eunice Vance term underrated as [ __ ]
but Tesla is so quirky I love them no
Joonas Venstre oh I just saw our spanner
quit Nikhil I told it before I could do
this all day
mother flippin poor load torch all those
videos where they heat up knives you're
welcome and cut through things
splish-splash say thanks I could do this
all day it's a very long list what the
hell is a radial born bearing oh oh yeah
I know what that is
yo-yos that thing in yo-yos I don't know
what it's called in English
I think it's called radial ball bearing
oh yeah we invented that mother Yes
Mother yo-yos made by us yo you wouldn't
exist unless we'd your welcome everyone
oh my god oh I'm sorry you want a gas
accumulator we got you fam I'm sorry you
want an AP separator that separates the
a from the beefs I'm sorry yes we
reinvented the wheel for some reason
omnidirectional wheel that's pretty cool
we reinvented the freaking wheel dude
the zipper say thanks to your pee-pee
right now and me I'll stop I'm sorry I
went on way too long oh this is an easy
bed team ninja losers easy don't you
have another cat to abuse not the hero
we deserve but the one we need Oh ninja
he deleted the tweet what I said all the
white man calls his son British women
cause you love hey for you don't have a
dad are you winning
[Music]
I feel hot crack eh that's a cool fan I
got the minecraft swords we're just
Swedish by the way you're welcome did I
mention that when Susan Wojcicki hits
100 kg self congratulating her Susan
Wojcicki Susan Wojcicki oh my god how
many subs does she have now all she hit
it oh man it thought oh matador boobs
are your most dear Susan Susan you did
so great
finally I can speak Swedish let me tell
it doesn't that oh your Swedish it
doesn't meet that big guys tambourine of
power gross one tambourine every milli
sub e let's get it come on I want to see
this to reach the moon pubes subscribe
or I river
Santa isn't real toddlers watching
because of the hint yeah you better
subscribe quick or I'll make an exposed
video I'll cancel Santa I don't care
I'll do whatever it takes my eye is
itching for some reason don't care I'll
still talk meet celebrating that an
internet Swedish man told me my pain is
large the tragedy and chaos of 2020 yeah
your penis huge well done you pass the
penis inspection congratulations I did
it I passed the penis expection online
are you winning this is an intro
it's a neat yes
[Music]
they can bring it on the water just
don't do monetize me transcending
mediums well done you got a large dick I
need to make a kid's channel who wants
to run it my time has come
blue [ __ ] kid Rises once again I want to
see it I want to see it brofist says
dick instead of pipi cooking video
livestream Thursday's with PewDiePie
let's play videos it's all coming
together
oh yeah it's been really fun doing
different videos it's mainly cuz you
guys encouraged it so I'm glad you guys
pushed me to it thank you
we were watching Titanic Felix turned
off the TV
as the iceberg shows up I think someone
can't handle his emotions
there's onion in here there's onion in
the air listen up you lush heads
alright everyone already knows how the
goddamn movie ends alright it's an
historical film what's the point
so what'd you do this is a life hack by
the way you watch Titanic great flip and
film super come through to watch
Romain's drama a little bit of intense
moments but never too far
stop watching halfway through and it's
just a comfy film you don't have to
watch the iceberg bit and that it makes
me uncomfortable
you want to watch a good old comfy movie
watch Titanic and just stop halfway
through I honestly it's a life hack
Poots webcam quality Pierce ad school
yeah okay yeah great come on the camera
is good now it's not gonna get better
than this so you might as well stop
complaining about the quality how to
convince your partner to become an epic
floor gang 20% PP increase check show
your partner your epic yo your skill
check also mention the fact that the
yo-yo couldn't exist without the without
the radial ball bearing which helps it
spin go spin spin haha check step to
teach your partner how to play
Tambourine step 3
let your partner set on the floor you
may also proceed to spit on ceiling
caution ceiling may spit back now yeah
just because I'm not on the floor
Lee doesn't mean any war is over I still
hate ceilings yeah that'll show one okay
mom escape yeah thank you
that's the great thing about a beard it
protects you from spits from the ceiling
as an armor I'm wearing here are you
winning son yes dad I'm winning I just
recorded an epic video and I hit the
table read so hard feel free to take
those two seconds and post it if anyone
ever asks what the PewDiePie channel is
it's time to go am I in my day no they
wanted to wish you happy birthday
oh I miss his birthday I'm the worst
father I don't deserve to say there are
you winning son mean you're killing me
Ranga thing before I cheated on him
things were amazing after I cheated on
him it changed it's also the fact that
she said why is he so untrustworthy why
is he so untrusting of me tap e to use
your engine oh my god I love that show
it's so funny some people are saying
that comments that he gets worst but I
don't know apparently they're still
together so there's no reason to he not
our business petition to have weekly
series called cooking with PewDiePie
alright so see you guys complain about
the switch pancakes not being Swedish I
know one that guarantees a guaranteed ly
guaranteed Garen is Swedish guaranteed
ly yeah I'm kind of jealous this is rich
attractive hey I'll take it has a cute
fiance and wife is is it still fiance
and I am just sad guys sitting at home
all day edit your boy found someone Oh
ah there's hope for people with anime
avatar guys bet you don't have this blue
but you don't have this screen but you
don't have the biggest ball the world
has ever seen that's cool finite it's
been like eight months I still have a
problem with this song because it's a
good-ass song more music coming soon
stop asking oh yeah
I made this entirely with dots gotta
check details to confirm that's so cool
how is that even possible
what a damn thank you so much I can't
believe you got so much detail goddamn
look at the beer dude thank you thank
you
that deserves an oh you already got a
ton but hey I'll get I'll add more how
are you sigh how you doing people want
to know
[Music]
I appreciate the effort of this normal
youtubers hey guys check out my new
Lambo PewDiePie hey guys check out my
new Tambo took a few weeks social media
break but now I'm back
what if I missed wide Putin oh yeah
that means sucks come on prepared my man
that's not true I'm stupid I made switch
pack it all someone made the recipe epic
what does it say you're really your
surname Wow is that non skimmed milk
oh it's almond milk oh all they make is
good actually that's fine all right
let's see that goddamn pancakes
good technique very nice all right let's
see the flip looks good that looks
better than mine she made a kiss idea
canceled not skimping out on the jam or
read am alright taste - yeah it is
there you have it you're welcome Swedish
pancake authentic when I was watching
the new camera video I realized that I
mean watching pewds since 2012 I'm 21
years now I can't believe how foods play
a big role in who I am today I've had a
rough childhood when I was started my
parents sent me to boarding school this
I stayed there for five years it was
quite a rough school and there was no
cell phones or Internet
she says Christ might as well send you
prison camp I remember when I go to VA C
I would watch your videos and try to day
me vacation and try to memorize them so
when I go back I could rewatch your
videos in my head and believe me it
helped a lot
time passes too damn quick I can't
believe you're 30 thank you for
everything really by the way I learned
English from watching your videos that's
amazing I can't believe it
now obviously I know a lot of people are
watching me I never realized it actually
had an impact on people's lives that's
crazy
thank you for watching hey if you're if
you're feeling down at least know that
you made me happy no one seems for me
this is so st. mr. piece donated ten
thousand no I forgot about mr. Bies I'm
sorry thank you for the simply mr. beast
it's been a while I could appreciate
some more simple to be honest
PewDiePie using a coke mentos style
intro is the equivalent of rickroll and
you can't change my mind
POV you are the coke melon intro with
good meme maybe we got another intro
sweet let's watch nice
[Music]
the stick nation production very nice
well done huge dick another one all
right this is the JIT quality okay maybe
a bit low framerate but I say oh god she
really died no make them yours
personalize your air pods with free
engraving only at Apple Apple is about
to get lawsuit you're done Apple don't
ever come near floor gang with your
overpriced garbage
whoa now this is quality try to make it
as simple as possible there is no there
that's cool
well done see this way see this way very
good I prefer gumball more the show
Carlo gumball isn't real
ricardo gamble isn't real hundred
percent both illiterates
oh this is a live intro Wow just lipo
save on there very nice whoa oh my god
[Music]
that's a worthy intro even that that's
amazing
show my dog it's so weird cause like as
soon as I hear it in the video I'm like
what what did I just say some reason it
doesn't register when I lose my goddamn
mouth a for my subscribers give me two
dollars I'll have two million dollars Oh
yikes cringe bro
goddamn yeah that's the goal that's the
goal huge mana mate I want a giant
tambourine my limit the size of my
peepee damn another amazing drawing
goddamn guess I need to do more
photoshoots everyone's using the same
reference material that's amazing thank
you big boy Draco oh very nice love this
style huge dick welcome I mean you thank
you I mean you know you know what you're
welcome Zoe doc you're welcome
jacksepticeye that's hard poor lab
laughs one of my favorite characters now
I can't believe people say they prefer
Jax playthrough because it takes the
game more seriously and respects it and
it makes it more in immersing I don't
understand what people mean I don't get
it true Viking indie hey what do you
train in the library yeah this is big
dream big brain time fit lit dude
reading pump iron immediately and don't
read no 15 authors that hasn't been dead
for at least 30 years otherwise cringe
might as well be a ceiling
[Music]
[Applause]
I got me published published it I sweat
react to through this before but if I
have it
goddamn so cool Finn isn't firm style I
raise a glass to my all-time favorite
YouTube channel and the most wholesome
reddit in the whole work cheers to you
might that's so dope
[Music]
Edgar agent E right there thanks for
amazing after I cheated
it changed before I smashed my ps4 it
was working after I smashed it
I understand it's so unfair Petey pyres
next cooking video should be bread so we
can all learn how to get women
let's Swedish type of bread connected
connected or Gabrielle I could sure I
could try in I kind of miss eating Thank
You Brett connect you bruh some butter
plus [ __ ] dude really clean up oh oh you
don't know about the legend of shuttin
critic area there's two things I asked
my parents there it is picture me shows
that they should [ __ ] pay me there's
two things I asked my parents to send me
[ __ ] the Gita and salty licorice that's
the two things I want from Sweden the
mouse it's so good you can put it on
anything anything it's made for meat and
grill but you put it on connect your bra
and bright salvation connect your primer
or sanitation to click that poor a
family skeleton spool roller yeah I
almost got grounded thanks Felix
subscribe infant or I will reveal that
Santa isn't real
Felix I was watching that I know my
fiber old cousin
anyway who said that who started crying
hey they're gonna find out sooner or
later ok
I always thought that the whole Santa
life was just a weird thing anyway
and I don't agree with it that's right
we need to cancel Santa
the supplying the kids they need to
understand that Santa is real I'm sorry
that was a joke I apologize don't cancel
me of course centers really bring
present epoch no no no I'm I gotta go
I'm done I'm flippin done thank you for
watching in our episode of hit like
buttons hit all the like buttons that
you find on the screen oh my god I
almost missed out on Sven made out of
pipe cleaners alright thanks for
watching thanks for all the new members
and I see you guys tomorrow
Hey
[Music]
it's time to race what was once
forgotten
what creatures far spells and poop
troops awaits hope tears coming to
Nintendo's wait
and remember it has a very big TV
pre-order promotion heavy
yeah we assetbook were sneaking around
the world